o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
G1
eu quero te fazer uma pergunta você tem
que ser levado a sério demais um Pois é
eu fui uma criança que me levei a sério
demais nasci cresci em Osasco e eu era
aquela criança que nos isso Java que não
corria para não suar Pois é e isso me
trouxe alguns problemas um deles foi não
me enturmar e quando a gente não sinto
turma a gente passa por um processo que
eu não sei se você sabe o bullying Pois
é o bullying é quando a gente fez jeito
a gente considera o excluiu Man adulto
também pratica bullying viu e quando a
gente exclui desconsidera o rejeito
alguém essa pessoa recebe altas doses de
cortisol é o hormônio do estresse Olha
só sem saber não tava recebendo altas
doses de cortisol
e por ser desconsideradas querida
rejeitada eu tive uma fase na escola que
tiraram 21 para ver quem ficava na
brincadeira comigo gente Passei por
algumas coisas complexas e esse acúmulo
de cortisol me trouxe uma conta aos 16
anos foi quando eu percebi que eu estava
me levando a sério demais eu tive um
processo na escola tava' xingando ela
tranquilamente lá de repente meu pé
começou a formigar mas perna começou a
formigar minhas mãos formigarem o meu
braço eu comecei a formigar inteira
começou me dar um desespero eu não tava
sentindo meu corpo mas estava consciente
excesso de cortisol limparam Pois é a
conta chegou 16 anos e me levaram para o
hospital pois eu voltei do hospital
falei mãe acabou em eu não quero mais
isso para mim eu quero mudar
e eu quero ser uma nova pessoa E aí
minha mãe muito sensata falou que tá bom
beleza e ela me mudou de colégio foi a
primeira vez que eu falei olhando dá
para ser leve eu sou livre Olha só
aquela alegria eu comecei a viver os
meus primeiros amigos eu tenho uma
relação excelente com eles até hoje mas
eu percebi que se levar a sério demais a
conta uma hora chega Pois é e aos 16
anos eu falei essa conta vai vir para
mim não e comecei a ser feliz comecei a
explorar amigo meio assim foi para os
esports Comecei a jogar futebol foi
jogar futebol nos Estados Unidos voltei
fui trabalhar como guia turístico Olha
só trabalhar como guia com adolescentes
eu viajava me divertindo um olha só que
eles só que aconteceu o mundo não é
assim Mariana você tem que levar um mais
a sério a vida é dura você tem que ir lá
para conquistar as coisas
Oi e aí eu deixei adult se chegar eu
abrir a porta o boleto bateu eu abri
deixei a seriedade entrar na minha vida
novamente e eu comecei a olhar aquilo
voltei para o mercado de trabalho que
uma experiência incrível e uma não tão
incrível que hoje eu agradeço mas nessa
experiência não tão incrível eu passei
pelo bullying de novo eu era considerado
excluído e rejeitada pelos meus colegas
de trabalho e isso me fez o que olhar
falar chega né foi a primeira vez que eu
falei eu preciso dominar a minha alegria
de se auto domínio que está tudo dentro
de mim e eu cheguei para o mundo eu
falei chega o número você pode ser sério
eu não beleza eu me entendido aqui e
parei de me levar a sério me encarei fui
em busca da minha felicidade fui ver
como que eu poderia fazer foi estudar
Inteligência Emocional fui entender como
achar essas respostas para essa vida que
e fala que é duro que a gente tem que
ralar a gente tem que ser sério você já
reparou que as você tá numa conversa
muito gostosa leve vem alguém falar
agora deu agora não consegue a gente
tava falando sério só porque a gente
tava rindo e aí eu resolvi ajudar o
mundo como que eu me ajudei vai ser Alto
do meio da Felicidade Quais foram os
caminhos que eu encontrei para acessar a
minha personalidade esse meu agente
secreto do humor Hum pra gente levar
para o mundo porque o humor gente humor
ele não é piada humor é sensação de
bem-estar e o que você tem feito para
elevar sua sensação de bem-estar
Ah pois é né A gente cresceu problema
assim ao engole o choro embora eu choro
A gente cresceu ouvindo que a vida é
dura demais Então quero que você pare
agora e fale assim a vida não é de hoje
tá tudo bem que tá ótimo aqui tá ótimo
só de Verdura não a gente pode ser leve
e a gente pode colocar nossa sensação de
bem-estar para cima o tempo todo a gente
cresceu intelectualizando tudo
e reparou que tudo que é mais sério é
mais importante
é para gente Para gente ser mais
inteligente a gente tem que ser menos
feliz será que é isso e tem uma
explicação para isso quando a gente tem
que intelectualizando demais quando a
gente quer resposta para tudo a gente
quer planejar tudo a gente quer
controlar tudo a nossa mente ela tá em
trabalhar assim ó trabalhando demais e
uma mente que trabalha demais ela não
abre as portas para o inesperado e a
gente não consegue ser feliz Poxa vida é
isso então quem tá intelectualizando
muito não consegue ser feliz a gente
precisa pausagem porque aquilo o nosso
corpo para ele tem energia ele que seja
movimento ele seja muito movimento a
nossa mente é o contrário ela precisa de
mobilidade
bom então para gente é mais feliz a
gente precisa para usar para ti que mais
vezes o nadismo é tão simples de fazer
nada você vai parar o assim eu não vou
fazer nada fazendo nada aqui ó fazer
nada em e alguém quer falar para você
assim sendo pode fazendo nada só falar
não tô fazendo nada mais nada de nada
nada não nada de nada tô aqui fazendo
O que é adulto não para para fazer nada
E aí você já sim já percebeu que criança
é um pacotinho de alegria né já nasce
com tudo para ser feliz e aos poucos a
gente vai criando umas camadas que vai
deixando a gente Mais sério mais duro
mas intelectualmente ativo a gente perde
aquela alegria de viver Então vamos
tirar essas camadas vamos pausar mais
vamos abrir a porta para o inesperado E
aí não é sim esperar o final de semana
esperar as férias para pausar é agora
ele já colocasse a reunião com você hoje
na agenda não ficar esperando amanhã a
no mar e depois no final do ano eu vejo
isso não é agora tá bom o vídeo para
você que ela fazer nada
oi para você para usar sua mente
e para trazer essa imobilidade para o
seu dia a dia
se você está entendendo porque a gente
era uma ênfase ao contrário né adulto
ficar sentado o dia inteiro pensando
pensando pensando fez o tempo só tem uma
pessoa
Oi e aí a gente não abre a porta para
alegria não abre a porta para a
felicidade eu quero dizer que você já é
perfeito você tem tudo tudo tudo tudo
que você precisa para você dominar sua
felicidade a resposta tá internamente
não tá lá fora tá aqui dentro
Me pare e faça essa pausa para você
marcar Saiu nenhum com você para sua
mente falar tô carregando porque a gente
lembra de carregar todos positivos que a
gente tem mais aqui a gente não é e a
positividade de alegria toda essa
conexão faz a sua bateria pressão
e eu quero que você carregue sua bateria
então assim pratique mais vezes o
nazismo porque dá para falar sério sem
ser certo quem se leva a sério demais
não tem tempo para sorrir e eu quero que
a gente seja feliz né Bora ser feliz
sabe por quê Porque ri é grátis